- I am a true California girl.
I am.
I love it here for so many reasons,
but mostly because this is a place
that is a year round destination
with so many amazing outdoor events.
We actually teamed up
with Visit California
to drop in on an event the other night.
Take a look.
We are about to crash a movie screening.
That's right, because in California,
the weather is so beautiful that you can
sit under the twinkling stars
and the gorgeous city lights,
and actually watch a movie outside.
But what you don't know is that the movie
is actually 50 First Dates.
So I'm gonna go and surprise some people.
Let's see how this goes.
Hi everybody.
(crowd applauds)
Hi!
My name is Drew Barrymore,
and I wanted to come and personally
present this movie to you tonight.
It just seemed like a
wonderful opportunity
on this gorgeous California
night in this warm weather,
to be able to enjoy a movie that is
happy and joyful and hopeful.
And ironically really talks about
the challenges we face in life.
I think this is why I've always wanted
to make films like a 50 First Dates.
So it's a pleasure to have gotten to do
movies that I think do
put you in a good mood.
And you know, if anyone has
a question about the movie,
I was there and I could answer
any fun trivia or facts.
I see a hand raised,
- Hi Drew.
- Hello.
- I've been a big fan my whole life.
So thank you for your work and
all that you've done
for making us happier.
- Thank you.
- I really appreciate it.
I guess I was wondering,
in context of this movie,
if there's ever been a day in your life
that you wanted to relive
over and over again.
- Oh my gosh, that's such a good question.
- [Woman] Thank you.
- It would definitely be
a day with my daughters.
Until I met them, life was
just, you know, fun and dandy.
But when I met them,
like everything changed.
So any day where the
three of us are there,
is the day I want to stay in permanently.
Thank you for asking me that question.
I saw you raised your hand.
- Hi.
I love you.
I love your show.
- I love you.
- I literally just got
here from Toronto today,
so this is a really interesting surprise.
- Welcome to California.
- Thank you.
So I know that you film
your show in New York,
so what's the reason that you're here?
- So one of the things
that we wanted to do
with season two of the show,
because season one, we weren't
able to travel anywhere,
and I always saw this show as something
we would take on the road.
I'm from California.
I now live in New York and
it's a really fun chapter,
we're not gonna lie,
but these are my roots.
I love California and nights like this,
and to see a skyline and greenery
is something that I miss so much.
There really is no place like California.
It's weird that you can be
at an ocean, a mountain,
a desert, and a forest
all within 30 minutes.
This is a very magical state.
So I just felt like kicking
the season two off here.
Do you want to ask one last question?
I see a raised hand right there.
- Thank you for taking the
time to answer some questions.
My mom came too, she's in town.
We are huge fans of yours.
Ever After is our all-time favorite movie,
as well as Never Been Kissed.
So I just wanted to know if you ever
had a favorite movie that
you enjoyed working on.
- You just named the two movies
that really changed my life,
and Charlie's Angels too.
(crowd applauds)
When it comes to filmmaking,
I wanted feelings at
the end of these films
and for Ever After, I
wanted people to feel like,
I am in control of my own destiny.
I wanted for 50 First Dates for people
to have faith and believe in
the goodness of people and love,
and Charlie's Angels, yeah,
I wanted to drive a stick shift
and get into fourth gear, maybe fifth.
But tonight I hope you let
everything fall away for a moment
and watch something that, I promise you,
we all made for you to feel good.
So thank you for letting me
invade your space tonight,
and may you have such a beautiful,
wonderful rest of your evening.
Thank you.
(crowd applauding)
- [Woman] We love you.
- I love you more.
(crowd applauding)
That was so much fun.
I really do love surprising people.
I love when people do it to me
and I've actually totally gotten,
gotten into doing it to people.
So that was really fun,
and you kind of never
know what you're gonna get
during a night out in California.
You might even bump into me.
I'm just saying.
(theme music)